means it's time alex to have a little
fun yeah las vegas now host mercedes
martinez joins us live from the mix 94.1
studios with what's trending hi mercedes
happy friday
happy friday you guys it's so good to be
here and we're going to kick things off
with twitter twitter is trending for its
newest features
now it's called super follow basically
accounts can now make certain tweets
available
to only people who pay to see it
now not everyone is happy about this
i'll tell you
the social media guru just announced
also that they're going to start a new
program called communities it's where
people can talk to their friends
or groups of people who have the same
interests as you so i guess we're gonna
have to start paying for
for alex and john's tweets if we really
want to see the good stuff apparently
mine will always be free they're not
worth much
also mr potato head has gone
viral after 70 years hasbro
has announced that the toy line will now
be called potato head just potato head
mr and mrs potato head
will still exist but the branding on the
box is changing
the company says they're trying to make
sure everyone feels welcome
in the potato head world john alex
the potato head world i didn't know
there's an entire galaxy of potato heads
all right
whole thing good to see okay you know
mercedes alex is a big post malone fan i
think your last concert was a post
malone show i believe yes
i'm aware live concert i'm aware of his
existence
this morning he's trending for reviving
a classic song mercedes
okay yeah he is really holding he's
holding this virtual concert tomorrow
and it's to celebrate the 25th
anniversary
of pokemon so he gave us a little sneak
peek of what to expect
posty covered hooties hit only want to
be with you
buddy tweak the lyrics just a little bit
take a listen
i'm such a baby
yeah instead of the dolphins the cowboys
make him cry because post malone
he's the biggest dallas cowboys fan
there is he
uh is so he he sounds so good in that
song i don't know what you guys
thought but hooty's lead singer darius
rucker he tweeted saying
that he loves loves loves it and he said
that the smile on my face
will not leave for a very long time guys
oh i love that yeah it has the posty
touch to it
i like it a lot absolutely and i think
darius loves the royalties as well
[Laughter]
well thank you very much mercedes we'll
track that down on youtube have yourself
a good rest of the friday we'll see you
in las vegas now later today thanks
mercedes thank you guys have a good one
have a great weekend